τι ήταν αυτό που σας έκανε να σχοληθείτε με τον εριθροστάττο χιλι νιακόσαδομήτα τέεα επια
την πρό αυτή φογά στους καταυλιεσμούς πραγματικάπαθακίδα ότι μπογούσαμε να ποργούσαμε να προσφεύουμε και πωςφεπρόσφερε
πάρα πολύ ο ελθώσταδος μεγαλώσατε με κάποιες γραμμές και απβαδοπούλου λόγο και του ονόματος του
πατέρα σας είχαμια φυσιοδολογική ζωή ένας άνθρωπος που είχε πολύ έτσι κουρτούίσως ήναν κι αυτό
ένα σημάδι ότι λίγο πριν πεθάνι περάσατε από τη γαλήναι για με στο παί εβεβες
τελευταίφογά διότι δυστύχος αρχισε να είχε ενοχλήσεις η σύληση του τάφου πως το αντιμετωπίσατεσις κυραμοάδοπου
δεν έκατάλαβα ποτέμο γιατί γίν ξερεται ότι τους τον βραμε γιατί ο ένας από τους
ένας υ αγιάτης που εβοήθεισε θανεται εκείνους που το έκαμα η κύρξανπράγματα σαν αυτό που
υπόθηκαν που σας ενόχλησαν τότεείχαναφήσει στο σπίτι δύο συνονικουους να όταν εξεκινήθησαντε συζητήσει τες βουλς
στη βυλή και πι έχου να στυνομικου σκέπτι δεν έχουν και ξ ονικό λας αδικήθηκε
όταν προσπάθησε για πρώτε σημογρατία θερετα δενξέω αναδικήθη κε με την έμια λά έγίναν πολλά
πειχνίδια τότε μίλες και φίλει άλλο έναντε έναλα ευποτια σήμερα μαζί σας φιλοξενούμενη μια κυρία
με πλούσιο φυλανθρωπικό έργο μια κυί με κάποια καιφαλέο όπως στην λένε πάρα πολύ για
την οποία δεν θα ακούσεις ποτέ κάτι άρνετικό η διαίτερη τημσήμερα εδώ στο αντέναλα ευπότας
αφού μαζί μας είναι η κυρίά φοτην υπαπαδοπούλου και απαβα εποδούλο η σας ευχαριστό πολύ
που αποδεχθήκατε να είστε σήμερα εδώστεο πότκα στο αντένα και εγώ χέγουμε που είμαι μαζί
σας και ελπίζωνα γίνει ο μια